as the americans built chicago so
chicago defines the americans [Music]
themselves
the image of Chicago is one of rebirth over the
ruins of Fort Dearborn a trading post was built
business sprouted like fireweed in the
ashes and these weren't the last ashes
place to live ugly to look at ugly to work in the
city was a machine to make things and do things in
beauty was a luxury poverty and the suffering
and despair that always accompany it
moved in and stayed these are constricted
individuals they are not constricted so much
from the environment but by the
environment within them [Music]
the ghetto the persisting ghetto that is the
heartland of so many great American cities
is a greater prison than the literal
prison of stone walls and iron bars
because here the stone walls and iron
bars smother the hopes of human beings
[Music] the jailer's name is
despair he grants no parole
he's the bottom line when you add it up
bad education plus no job equals dependence
equals a self-image of nobody going
nowhere well i've been laid off about
better than a year now about a year and a half or
so things got real tight and rough and uh you know
everything looked like just just stopped you know
just come to a halt and there was a big layoff
and right now things just so bad i just
don't even know what to do you know and
everywhere i go it seems to be the same what they
are they got they haven't got anything open right
now they'll notify you later well during
this time that i've been laid off it's uh
it's just been bad cause my wife where
she works the job that she have um
she uh only get paid twice a month and it just
doesn't enough money to really support the
whole household you know and uh it's just it's bad
because she take her little money that she get and
by the bills running like there is then we have
telephone we got light bill we got gas bills to
pay and uh then that's the grocery bill which is
the main event then everything have to come out of
her check and she only gets about every two weeks
you get paid and you know it's it's really bad and
uh and i've been running back and forth to my
unemployment trying to get my money down there
since june and each and every time i go down
there i hear the same old story which i keep
repeating to my landlord and it's really rough
i haven't been paid since uh sometime in june
right i mean i got a lot of expenses with my kids
when i know i got a lot of running around to do i
take my son over to my mother-in-law's house and
i leave him over there doing the biggest portion
of the week you know there have been tens we had
to take them over there and leave them because of
lack of food and everything and uh until you can
you know try and get some because children can't
understand when you they cry on your face
and looking for something i'll say hungry
you can't feed them words you know and by me not
having to get no income right now it's really bad